[Music]
we've come up with three of our favorite
calls and they are centered around
marriage so if you're not married you
got to listen if you're thinking about
getting married and you're engaged you
got to listen and if your marriage has
falling apart you're trying to figure
out a first Christmas or a 10th
Christmas on your own you're not
[Music]
alone oh ho ho this is John with the Dr
John delone show and it is
Christmas Christmas if you're listening
to this show right now and let's be
honest you probably shouldn't be but
maybe um you're listening to this the
day after Christmas or maybe it's
Christmas and you've opened presents and
your family's already complaining and
fighting or they've gone back to bed and
you are staring off into space or you're
out for a walk so that you
can breathe or maybe your family just is
all sitting around a a fire opening
gifts listening to the show I hope
that's not happening actually I kind of
do hope that is happening that that
would make for some fun SL awkward
conversations whatever the reason you
have you have joined us this morning or
this evening or whenever you're
listening to this show we're so glad
you're here it is Christmas and as a
special Christmas gift what we've
decided to do today is go back into the
Vault into the archives and pull out
some of the greatest most important
shows ever and we've come up with three
of our favorite calls actually your
favorite calls and they are centered
around marriage so if you're not married
you got to listen if you're thinking
about getting married and you're engaged
you got to listen if you are married and
everything's great plug in if you are
married and things are falling apart and
Christmas just solidified what you
already knew got to hang with us and
check it out and if your marriage has
falling apart
and you're trying to figure out a first
Christmas or a 10th Christmas on your
own check it out you're not alone so
here is a best of marriage shows curated
for you we're so glad that you're with
us I wish you guys the best and I hope
you got everything you wanted for
Christmas but more importantly I hope
you're surrounded by people who love you
and who care about you and even if
they're annoying you know they've got
your back here we go let's go to Rebecca
in m Medford Oregon what's up Medford uh
not Medford what's up Rebecca how we
doing hi Dr John thank you for taking my
call I'm a really big fan I really
appreciate it thank you so much I'm
grateful for you what's
up um I'm just wondering um I found out
some very shocking things 10 months ago
um I found it out all in one
day um my question is how can I heal
after finding out my husband has been
keeping secrets for me throughout our
entire 28y year marriage whoa what kind
of
Secrets um I just had a I I'm not one to
check phones um babysit as I call it
check uh you know check his computer um
but I had a a weird feeling um and I
checked his
computer and when I found out was
completely overwhelming um he had
reached out to an
ex-girlfriend um 2 years
prior um nothing came of it but he had
reached out um I found out he had a porn
addiction um lots and lots of porn it
seemed to have it escalated it looked
like into some Kinks I had no
idea that he was into he was reaching
out to
couples um he was in chat rooms um the
way that he was speaking to other people
was definitely not the person I knew
we're very close we've been best friends
for so long we just you know were very
close we have each other's backs I know
him inside and out and I feel like he
knows me except I have never once lied
to him the way he he was speaking to
these people um was crass um
graphic but the most disturbing to me is
that he had
showed to these random online people
photos of me um sexualizing me
describing my
measurements um and a desire of me to be
with a man another man in front of
him they weren't nude photos of me but
they were racy photos you know just
shorts um and like a low cut tank top
that you know I just would never ever in
a million years think that he would
share that with someone um and all these
things I found
out were were so shocking um and I just
found out more and more stuff as I as I
read through I started crying um I felt
like I had been kicked in the stomach um
and that everything I knew about
him was it just switched in a moment's
time um I I just I had no idea he felt
this way that he was even capable of
doing something like this um so this was
10 months ago um yeah tell me about the
last 10 months how's that gone um well I
I kicked him out we have a a a trailer
so I kicked him out um to get some space
um I was Furious uh I I couldn't stand
even look at him how did he how did he
take that did he did he say I understand
or did he go k screen at first no at
first he um gaset me and made excuses is
until as when I approached him I gave
him a chance to be honest on his own and
he was not and it wasn't until I
presented him with black and you know
there and black and white what I read
and he could not deny it anymore and
then he became no he left
willingly um he let me kick and scream
um he took it and then he was just he
wrote me a letter after letter after
letter while he was gone just he's in
deep shame
I'm extremely remorseful um
crying um it's been a rough 10 months um
very up and down and he I mean he went
so far as he made a list of everything
he was going to do to get
better and has followed through with
most of it um he made you know he became
very
transparent um he
put um you know um locks on anything
porn related um he just quit overnight
it seems just overnight and um all of
that I appreciate he's been trying very
very hard he did promise to go to
counseling and get us in marriage
counseling if I would agree and that has
not happened um we've actually been for
10 months he's been fighting with the
insurance company and not getting a
response yeah I I don't care I don't
care about that um yeah uh so how can I
help you sounds like just a the whole
world blew
up um it blew up um I didn't know how we
would go on right um I I felt trapped
sure I felt absolutely trapped
overwhelmed and we had just moved out of
state and I thought I would I told him I
would have never made this move with you
if I had known this was going on sure
the hardest part for me now yeah how can
I how can I help you yeah from just my
point of view is that I feel I don't
trust myself I don't trust him I don't
trust any other men so I feel helpless
in that I feel
disoriented um and the anger like I do I
do really well we do we do fine and then
all of a sudden the anger will pop up
and it keeps popping up and I know I
want to heal from this I want to get
better it it's going to take a long time
and how
[Music]
long 11 months four days three hours um
so good I got my calendar working it
down put a star by it'll it'll it'll
just clean right up right there um yeah
okay couple of things I it's very very
rare that this doesn't
happen
that he hasn't come fully clean M so
that's number one yep okay yep um number
two it's very rare that this happens
that somebody says I was completely
blown away caught off guard that
remember that movie the six sense with
Bruce Willis and remember the end of
that movie and you're like oh no and
they actually do a really amazing job of
showing you all the places where you
missed
it yes and it's easy to look back on
your life and go oh oh no oh no right
and that's that sense
of I think I knew this all along or
parts of this or not all of it but oh my
gosh this makes sense and then I
remember this conversation I remember
this question and then that's that
feeling you get which is most people
don't realize that when somebody's
cheating on you or Unfaithful in any
number of ways the most disorienting
thing is you don't trust yourself
anymore like man how did I miss all of
this right y um
I also think that this is a little
unique situation and here's why
um it feels like you don't know this guy
and you can't trust this guy and
everything about him is a lie that's not
true okay he is the guy that sat with
you and I'm just going to make up some
stuff I don't know if any of this is
true but he is the guy that sat with you
when your mom got sick he was the guy
that showed up on Christmas morning like
those things happened and those are real
and you can't throw all of that out that
happened okay okay um and it's real easy
to be like none of this is real none of
this is true that's that's a defense
mechanism it is the harder part is
dealing with the Paradox of you sat with
me and held my hand while my dad passed
away and then you went home and got on
our computer and did that that's a
harder thing to deal with than just
swinging that thing my husband's perfect
my husband's the devil it's always in
the middle always in the middle okay
here's where I think this is a little
bit unique
um and I hope I say this the right way
in a way that comes across that makes
sense he clearly violated your trust and
he violated um he kept secrets from you
okay yeah when it comes to things I'm
interested in or it comes into a fantasy
world um that's not uncommon okay it's
heartbreaking and it makes people sad
but it's not
uncommon okay where he crossed a line
for
me is he took pictures of you and put
him out to the world mhm he brought you
into a
situation that um in a way that is for
me personally is above and beyond a
normal guy got started looking at
pornography and kind of got sucked down
a rabbit hole and ended up you know in
some chat rooms and just it becomes
Dungeons and Dragons a pornographic
Dungeons and Dragons right it's a
fantasy world so super separate from The
Real World okay that as crazy as it
sounds that that doesn't bother me that
I mean it bothers me in the clearly
hurting people it's not weird or crazy
okay yeah what's weird and crazy is
taking pictures of your wife and putting
them on the Internet and saying hey any
any Seekers here's her measurements that
to me is such another layer of a
violation here that um I I I have a hard
time coming back from that to be honest
with you because yeah he's he dragged
you into something that you don't even
know you're being dragged into
no idea right and so I want to validate
your I want this to work but I don't I
can't seem to make
it right like your hurt and violation is
very very very real above and beyond
what I would call and I hate to use this
word it's just the world I'm in a
normal um pornography addiction or a
normal
um uh violation like someone's someone
is you know spending time erotic time in
a fantasy world this is above and beyond
and so the question you have to ask
yourself
is are you playing
house or are you playing Mary just on
your terms meaning you kicked him out
but I still go to dinner with him we've
still been intimate we're still friends
we're still hanging out all the time but
then I just get raged out and what
you're doing is
you're you're trying to heal a wound but
you keep pulling the Band-Aid off
yeah is that fair yes yes okay
absolutely you've got and and I hate to
bring his feelings into this but they
are a part of it because y'all been
married a long time and his feelings are
a part of you whether you want them to
be or not um it's can be cruel too as it
could be it could be well it's a form of
punishment I'm gonna punish you through
this right and that doesn't help anybody
do anything that's that's that's a waste
of energy and time what you have to
decide is what do I need right now and
I'm telling you just as your friend if
you need I need to cut off contact with
you for a
season feel fully empowered and no it is
Hell on the other side of that yeah it's
lonely it's sad it's heartbreaking and
that doesn't mean it's the wrong thing
okay okay and yeah if everybody's
telling you you just leave him you
forget this guy's a bum whatever and you
say this is my husband and we're gonna
figure this out I said till death do his
part come with May I'm here um that's
going to be a bumpy ride too and so
maybe the best gift I could give you is
there is no smooth ride out of
this both the hard part is nobody knows
that's right except I have a I have a
therapist but I just needed to talk to
you to even say it out loud yeah because
nobody knows they think he's perfect
yeah and so you've heard me say this
from the great David Kessler grief
Demands a witness and what's H what
you're what you're experiencing right
now that anger that Rage that's grief
yeah that is we set this sucker up dude
and you blew it up yeah right blew it up
it feels like grief it is that's exactly
what it is you are mourning the death of
what was and now what you get to choose
is what is going to be and if we if you
choose for what is going to be with him
great yall going to have to work really
hard and you're going to have to get a
new architect to help you draw a new
building and you're going to have to get
new contractors to help you build
something totally new cuz what you had
is over it's gone it is yeah and if you
choose I'm moving into a duplex I'm I
don't want another big building that's
another Avenue for you as well um but I
haven't seen that very
successful
W without some
space okay and I have never seen
somebody do this successfully by
themselves without without telling
people out
loud
they're going to be um you know I mean
you can probably guess my fear in that
is that I don't want people to judge my
husband um yeah
but feel isolated I feel so isolated
right and you are continuing to prop up
the image of this perfect little family
that you had you have to let that go
because it's not
real yeah you're right you're right and
maybe the first step is calling a close
friend and letting them letting her know
I'm about to blow your
mind they they will fall down in shock
it it I mean I I can you know I they
will go through a a fraction of what I
went through when I found out because I
why are you protecting them why are you
protecting
him I'll tell you why you've been
protecting him your whole
marriage yeah oh I have yeah I know your
whole Mar you protecting him at some
point Rebecca you have to decide that
you're worth being well and you're worth
being whole even if that means what what
you the fantasy land you've kept duct
taped together for 20 or 30 years is no
more
yes what they say what if they say
things back that actually hurt me they
will they will say stupid things like
well what did you do is it such a big
deal like you will get all that stuff
right and really quickly you will be
able to determine how close these
friends actually
are but let me tell you the word like
the word that we're dancing around here
that I hate more than anything is
vulnerability you only way forward to
heal is to vulnerability literally means
to roll over and expose your belly so
that another animal can come kill you
and hoping that they choose not to and
that's what it feels like right oh
that's fear yeah oh my gosh so let me be
very clear your friends could roast you
they could destroy you
mhm they
can yeah but if you don't find people to
talk to this will you will be the
casualty
here yeah it's so isolating I feel disor
I feel disoriented it is and when you
start saying these things out loud and
seeing the shock on their face you're
going to get a new perspective of what
you're experiencing so before the day is
over your homework assignment is to call
two
friends and invite them over and tell
them
everything all of it everything even the
stuff you left out which I guarantee you
left stuff out of this
call and maybe open up to your friends
and say I G to I'm going to need
help practicing not protecting him
anymore I'm going to need help waiting
through all this grief all this shame
all of this I should have said something
a long long long time ago I've had these
feelings in my guts for years and I just
ignored
them you're going to need help
practicing trusting Rebecca again and in
many ways it's going to feel like you're
going to rehab and learning how to
[Music]
walk I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry I'll be here with you every step
of the way call anytime email anytime
and I'd love to have you back on the
show and we can figure this thing out
together as we go but you got to have
two people that you call today invite
them over in person tonight have that
conversation that as uncomfortable as
it's going to be is where the healing
will
begin this episode is sponsored by
better help hey it's delone this time of
year there can be a lot of anxiety and a
lot of drama but it can also be great
but it can also be a mix of everything
right especially when it comes to giving
gifts maybe your family makes super
thoughtful hand made things or they
expect you to spend a million dollars or
maybe you just like experiencing time
together or pick up random gift cards
last minute things like gift giving can
make us bananas so no matter how hectic
it gets especially around gift giving
remember to take care of yourself
whether it's going easier on yourself
during tough moments or having to say
hey we don't have enough money to buy
all these gifts or treating yourself to
a Day of Silence remember to give
yourself some love this holiday season
and if things get too heavy if thinking
about dealing with your family and all
of the drama gets to be too much give
better help a try better help is
flexible because it's online so it can
fit into your busy holiday schedule just
fill out a short questionnaire to get
match with the licensed therapist and
you can switch therapist at any time for
no extra charge in this season of Chaos
in love and sadness and all of it rolled
up to one give yourself what you need
with better help visit betterhelp.com
delone today to get 10% off your first
month that's betterhelp
hp.com
delone right let's go to ailia in
Asheville North Carolina what's up
opilia hi how we doing oh you know
hanging in there oh you know oh man so
what's going on um so I am calling to
see how to reconnect with my husband
after I broke up with my boyfriend this
will be good go ahead fill me in yeah so
I don't know blame covid or deployment
or that my a score of six I don't know
we had marriage problems and we thought
the way to fix it was to go to polyamory
and try to fill it in with other people
who were more emotionally connected and
that obviously ended in a great big b of
burning fire yeah tell me about so first
tell me about how y'all came to that
conclusion who came to who so I came to
him I was presented with the offer from
a mutual friend of ours and because I
was talking to him about our problems
and he was like I'll sleep with you
basically yeah I'll sleep with you I'll
be your emotional connection I you know
that will be great for all of us I I'll
take one for theia exactly what hey what
a great guy um fantastic there's a lot
of people in the world that would have
just not done that and but man wow and
so you sit down with your husband and
you're like so I've got an offer for you
how'd that go um at first he's like I
don't understand why and then he was
like well I can have someone as well so
we might as well just try it and then it
was about 6 months of like lust puppy
love happiness of yeah I can
have attention when my husband's not
giving me any and then it end up being
that the person treating me like
terribly and then I broke it off and now
we're trying to just kind of stand here
in the ashes like well now what do we do
did your husband date anybody yeah he
did and how does that sit with
you at the time I didn't care I was just
happy that we could all be doing this
like amicable adults like quotation
marks around that and then now I don't
like it as much now that I'm realizing I
still want to be with my husband and
want to fix all the things that are
broken in our relationship so what has
broken in your
relationship um it's more of the lack of
emotional connection we got married at
18 and didn't know who we were or what
was happening and I had a bunch of
childhood trauma that I've been in
therapy now for two years finally
working through and now that I'm getting
healthier I want to actually turn around
and like fix the issues in my
relationship ship rather just being in
survival
mode and how's your husband
doing um you know he's just there he's
he started therapy finally he's more
than just there ailia
like like how's he doing because he
watched here's the thing he watched his
wife come and say listen you're not
meeting this need for me I think I found
like this really giving kind guy said he
would be happy to step in and have none
of the emotional support and all of the
sexual intimacy support again great guy
world class and
um and then he watched you go off and
and basically fall in love with somebody
yeah and yeah he hung around at home
how's he doing
now um he hasn't actually talked about
it really I mean he said that he was
okay with it when it was happening and I
was very honest about all of the
feelings and emotions and anytime he he
wanted details about like weekends we
spent together something I would tell
him and he hasn't said anything I can't
honestly say I've asked though yeah yeah
I I was giving my question does he have
permission to speak into that or two I'm
just trying to roll through that in my
mind
and like sitting down with my wife and
having that conversation and I
imagine everything would be so
compressed I would I think my body would
take over at that point and just numb me
out you know what I mean like that' be
the only way to get through the day um
so so here's my belief is
that give me give me a let me before I
give me my beliefs um give me
a describe to me what you felt with this
new person in month
one
um like I was happy that I was getting
attention and that somebody was
underneath that like um I mean there was
shame honestly underneath it underneath
that I'm not looking for negative things
um um okay like what did you
feel I mean I didn't eat for two weeks
if that's what you're asking no the the
most common word that we hear in this in
this world when somebody cheats on
somebody when somebody um even has like
a greed non monogamy for a season the
word most common heard is the word alive
I felt alive again yeah and it feels so
it's just like cocaine it's fireworks
it's cotton candy it's the greatest
feeling after feeling quote unquote not
alive for so long I don't think this had
anything to do with this other guy at
all I think it had everything to do with
you and for some reason in the
relationship you are currently in you're
marriage you've
chosen
death and then for some reason you chose
life with somebody who's abusive and
took advantage of you and um I'm not
saying all people take advantage of all
people but this guy clearly saw an
opportunity and um am I right he didn't
treat you well right right yeah I mean
at first it felt like it and then no
yeah so um but that even even that your
willingness to take that sort of this
some of this is really great and some of
this is terrible but it all felt alive
right and so my question to you is why
are you choosing to not be alive in your
marriage because life's so short man we
get one
shot I think we just got
complacent we I mean we've known each
other basically our entire lives and we
stopped trying
and I didn't think that we could go back
to trying so this other Avenue looked
really good and so now you're back to
wanting to try again tell me what you've
tried how when's the last time you slept
with with somebody else over a year ago
okay so um y'all called it off right you
said no that was a terrible idea I just
yeah and then we tried to stay friends
for a bit and that obviously didn't work
either so then it's been about four
months since all communication stopped
okay so now you and your husband have
y'all called this
off yes okay and so now you're staring
at each other being like so what now yes
what have you
tried um we went to a marriage Retreat
together and didn't really get anything
out of that um we have a vacation
planned to Iceland later like in the
fall time um that's yeah that's pretty
much it so you just gave me two more
firework shows
uhuh and you need to hear me say that's
not how Desir is
built okay those are fun I mean I mean
don't get me wrong those are fun and a
blast and it's cool to shake the snow
globe up and it's cool to change
environments that's all great this is a
daily choice that I want to be
alive I want to be alive in my skin this
is a daily choice that me and this guy
are going to sit across the table and
say we got one shot at this we we did
something stupid it didn't help us at
all and now we're living in the ash of
this so what we're going to have to do
is we're going to have to start this
thing over which is awesome and we're
going to build something totally new and
the cool thing about it is you get to
build something totally new but you got
to stop with the well guess we just quit
trying and we've known each other half
for life all that crap none of it
matters I could care less about any of
it everything is about what are we going
to do
tomorrow and what are we going to do
today you know what I mean cuz you you
come bearing all these excuses and
honestly I don't care about your Aces
score I do cuz I love you and you know I
love talking about trauma and stuff we
could have that conversation all these
things you're working through which is
fantastic at some point you have to
decide I'm worth living alive in my own
skin which means I'm going to I'm worth
living alive in my
relationships which means I'm worth when
things are a little running a little bit
low that's okay because it's cold
outside and I'm going to have some
communication and some practices with my
husband that we know how to turn the
heat back up when it's time and until
you can make and that's hard that's what
I like that's adult stuff it's tough man
it's boring it's day after day after day
and holy crap it's worth it it's worth
every step of the way if he'll play
along will he play yeah he will he he's
so into keeping the relationship going I
think that that was part of it too is
that he wanted to keep me happy and so
he agreed to it so you're gonna have to
process that shame and say that out loud
have you told him that because here's
the thing now you're gonna start beating
yourself up over it
yeah right yep
completely and he doesn't
need yet
another you don't need this you know
what I mean yeah so can you forgive
you can you forgive y'all and put a
period at the end of it and then go
excavate this thing and build something
new I'm gon to have to I can't build
anything on
shame you're you're right but millions
and millions and millions and millions
of people
do
okay I guess just what's the Practical
steps then I don't know if I've ever
been taught how to live in the every day
yeah so here's some practical stuff the
first thing is before you go on like
another marriage Retreat or something
spectacular here's the thing those
things come with a lot of pressure
and if there's still smoldering Ash that
pressure can it can just lead to
something
combustible okay and so when I'm going
to enter into like if my wife and I
going to go to a retreat of some sort
we've got a plan as to what're we're
going in to get out of this thing if
we're going on vacation like we talk
about in our house what's this do we
need this just to be a reckless wheels
off weekend together do we need just do
you need to sleep and I just I'm gonna
go for hikes or what like we are really
intentional about what the plan is
otherwise we both go in with different
plans and then we both go in different
plans we have different fantasies about
what's going to be on the back end of
this thing we're all going to be all in
love again no we're not that guy just
slept the whole weekend or we're going
to have crazy sex all weekend we're
going to reconnect and find not really
just want to go to a movie I'm tired
right and my knee hurts like whatever
the thing is and so you have to be super
intentional way in advance and so okay
here's what it looks like number one it
looks like you being honest with the
shame and honest with the
secrets and either there's a couple of
things you haven't told him
yet not and I'm not talking about gory
details about whatever weekend get away
or whatever I'm not talking about that
I'm talking about you this is a terrible
idea and you knew it while you were in
it and you need to say that out loud or
it what you don't think it was a
terrible idea and you gave it a shot and
then you realized halfway through was a
ter you just need to be honest shame
eats secrets for breakfast so there's
got to be a season of honesty and you
have to give him a safe space to be
honest
too okay and he will probably say things
that are hard to hear is that fair
totally fair yeah okay have you been
totally honest with him
100% yeah I have okay then this will be
about creating a space for him to talk
and then here's the goal what are your
needs so I'm going to ask you that what
do you need what makes you feel alive
what made you feel
alive be feeling seen by the person
seeing that I was having a rough day
without actually saying it or that my
family went off on one of their drunken
tangents again and I could actually
express my emotion to the person and
have them be supportive like I need to
feel seen and supported okay here's what
a great gift is and this is not in any
Hollywood movie okay okay you being
really clear with him about what being
seen looks like okay and in the moment
when you are not feeling seen you say it
not angry and not out of Rage but out of
you're a teacher and it's a gift this is
a moment when I need you just to come
hug me and say I'm so sorry your day was
hard and say nothing
else okay okay the same as you gave this
other knucklehead um that benefit of the
doubt like I like this in bed or I like
that you taught him those things teach
your husband the the important stuff
okay okay fair fair tot and he gets to
tell you what he needs and by the way
being seen is just one because being
seen is part one of I need you to see
all of me and please still love me and
for a kid with a six on the aces score a
lot of people have had their way with
you both emotionally and otherwise and
you have a
spinning uh like a fusion Center in your
heart that tells you what you're worth
and it is 1% of what the truth is okay
okay am I right yes yeah you are okay so
you're going to have to let him tell you
what his needs are and you can't fly off
the handle and you can't shut
down right run away that's my there we
go you go hide there you go you can't
shut down you got to stay present with
him and say I need you to teach me will
you walk alongside me in this and then
you're going to have to in the same
conversation preferably over a meal I
like him over a meal that's just me
because I like eating when I'm sad and
that's not a sad thing I just I just eat
my feelings and so there we go so you
know you don't have to you can do it on
a hike or whatever um and then you have
to say in one year I want to this to
feel and look like
this in two years in five years I want
this thing to look like this this thing
being our marriage and if our marriage
is not alive it's just a reflection of
what I'm putting into it and a
reflection of what he's putting into
it okay okay so hear me say this um I
know of no quality data
that suggests an open marriage solves
anything I just I haven't seen the data
it makes no sense okay um I've seen some
crappy crappy studies and I know it's
super cool to talk about with like yeah
bro we're adults we can just be adult
that's just stupid you know what I mean
I also told myself when I turned like
was an adult that I could eat Taco Bell
every day and that was a terrible choice
too I'm an adult bro I can just do
whatever I want not great right and so
here's the deal
um you have to decide what we want this
thing to look like and you're going to
reverse engineer it you're going to be
curious with each other you're going to
be patient I do think um if you're both
invested in this thing you can have an
extraordinary marriage moving forward I
really believe
that okay but you have to decide he's
worth it and you have to decide that
you're worth
it he can't materialize into your
soulmate he's going to become your
soulmate after 25 years of grinding
things out and if yall rebuild something
beautiful and powerful and
strong
man then you look back and say look what
we did together and he's going to be
like remember that time you and you're
going to be like shot up stop we're not
talking about right okay fair yes yes
it's totally fair okay okay all of this
starts with you getting with your
counselor that you're still seeing and
say I'm TI I'm tired of carrying these
bricks of Shame around we're going to
start working on setting them down so
that will be about writing some that'll
be about um you know they'll have a
process with you with your therapist
every therapist Works a shame and if if
they don't God help you go get another
therapist okay but this is going to be
about building something together with
him and hearing me say you are worth a
marriage that is
alive practice
desire it is a practice what do you need
what are the ons and offs so here's two
things I'm going to send you a copy of
own your past change your future of a
new book so stay on the line here and I
also want you to get a copy of Emily
neos's book come as you are um it's a
book about sex intimacy for women but
it's incredible for I I I've just found
it a really invaluable resource um
there's probably be a lot of stuff in
there that you don't need to hear but
there's some incredible sections on offs
and on and gas pedals and brakes and
this idea about sexuality and intimacy
and how to have conversations together
inside of a marriage um and there's
going to be stuff in there you don't
like blow like move on past it it's like
all books are going to be that way
you're going to find stuff in my book
that you don't like too my book's going
to walk you through okay you've got a
mess you got to own it and then now what
are you going to do moving forward and
it'll give you a blueprint for moving
forward there and her book will give you
some conversations to have with your
husband and he needs to read it too
right thank you for being honest
and set the bricks down man let's
excavate this whole thing and let's
start a new and let's build something
beautiful if you've listened to my show
any amount of time you've definitely
heard me talk about Thorne Thorn is an
incredible supplement company that makes
what I think are the best supplements in
the game I've taken Thorn for years way
before I had a show as you've probably
heard from listening to other podcast or
just walking through a local corner
store there are a million different
supplements all claiming they the next
great thing for all sorts of ailments
almost all of those claims and products
are either lying not good products are
just a waste of your money Thorn is one
of the very few supplement companies
that make Pure Clean tested and backed
by science supplements no fluff no
gimmicks no nonsense Thorn is what I
take personally and it's what I give to
my kids and make no mistake supplements
of this quality cost more than the
nonsense you see in gas stations so I've
partnered with Thorne for an incredible
25% off discount for our deloney show
listeners go to thorne.com
delone choose what you want add it to
your cart create an account and when you
check out 25% off will be knocked off of
the entire order and here's the best
part that discount sticks around for
Life go to thorne.com thelet you/ delone
check it
out Natalie in Atlanta Georgia what's up
Natalie how we doing hi I'm pretty good
how are you good I love uh pretty good
what's what's the uh what's the not
pretty part I can't wait um well it's
unfortunate actually so I'm a little
nervous just because I haven't told
anyone and it's like now I tell the
world so this is just great but okay
before before you say this why did you
pick this this forum to do this um
because I need advice from a trustworthy
Source other than Google and I listen to
your show and um Google is not a good
place I found it's a dark sad place yes
yeah a lot of strange information but
it's the show has been helpful to me and
it's a trustworthy source so I came here
um to get some advice I appreciate that
I'll do the best can you'll get what you
pay for how about that okay great um so
I have made a horrible mistake in about
two months ago I found myself in an
unhealthy relationship with someone at
the
gym um I wait back out are you married
are you married yes I am married that's
the key that's the key problem um we
have been married we're about five years
any kids five years two children two and
four okay um um so I wanted to do a
fitness competition and I found myself
at the gym a lot and there was a guy
there trainer and basically started you
know helping me out with some workouts
we started talking and it went too far
um my husband knows um well he started
talking to me we met for coffee and then
the part did you sleep with them we
actually ended up sleeping together yes
which is the part that my husband
doesn't know he knows everything except
for that because immediately I just
feared risking like I was scared of
losing everyone and I was so stupid and
I was like just scared so I immediately
lied and blocked him from everything I
have not communicated with him since
then it's been over two months but now
I'm like well great when it was all
horrible I lied and now I don't know if
I should rehash this cuz things have
been going really well well and like
we've really surrounded oursel with a
great community and church family and
counseling and I've have lied so hard
about this one thing yeah among every
single person because in my head I was
like I'll just never ever bring this up
and now I'm like do to move forward I
need to know whether or not I should
tell
him the fact that you're calling tells
me that you know the answer to
this well Google said otherwise I was
like well maybe I could get out of
this maybe that's not a good idea
um so you number one
bravery bravery thank you for saying
this out
loud go back and when you when you
listen to this call your voice changes
after you say it out
loud
okay take a big deep breath and then
drop your shoulders all the way down
so in your gut what do you think you
should
do um I probably need to tell them no
probably like what what do you need to
do I feel like I need to tell him
because I feel like if I don't it's just
going to
be preventing us I guess from truly
living honestly yeah
will this end
everything
I I don't know if it will I don't think
it will I just think it's gonna make it
harder I don't know what it'll do I mean
he is definitely forgiving and really
understanding but I mean y y'all have
been in counseling and you've talked
about this and we've talked about
everything ex and I've just totally
denied doing anything more than just
communication meeting him all that okay
so I am just I'm like oh my goodness and
y'all just hooked up one
time yes it was the hookup and then done
and everything kind of hit the fan like
as in he found out about us
communicating and and it was like almost
like a rescue for me because it was just
not going to go well from there yeah um
that's right but when everything's
starting to look better I just hate
having to rehash all this
yeah that's why I've tried to find a way
out I guess what does your counselor
tell
you um well I've actually we have never
met oneon-one so we're doing it through
our church and it's a couples's
counseling okay and so I still haven't
even been honest with the counselor
because I would have to say it in front
of both of them and I'm
like I don't know if he lowkey knows or
something but because I don't know but
he hasn't really told me anything he
about it because no one
knows so here's what I'll tell you your
husband
knows okay and he
doesn't he might not know that y'all
slept
together he might not know that y'all
did anything above what you told
him but he knows there's a gap between
the two of you yes and he's going to
counseling he's doing what he thinks
he's supposed to be doing mhm and that
Gap is getting wider because as he leans
in there's a part of you that leans out
because you
know is that right yeah that would be
accurate and so what I'll tell you is
beyond the right thing and the Integrity
thing and all that
stuff you're torturing a man that you
love and he doesn't even know
it now I sound like I'm talking out both
sides of my mouth I said he he knows but
then he doesn't even know it he knows
there's a gap there and he doesn't know
what it
is
right right I see
that and in some ways it feels better
because he's trying to do everything he
can to jump over that thing and you are
too there's a part of you that's trying
too and there's a part of you that's
anchored to still chain to that other
thing
right right so here's what I'll tell you
I'll tell you you screwed up and you
know that
mhm the season of Life y'all are in with
a 2-year-old and a
four-year-old
um is hard and you're not the only one
that's ever done that okay not trying to
make it right I'm trying to say you're
not alone right and you screwed
up and the measure now is what's next
that's what you can
control
yeah okay so you called me knowing what
I'm going to say anyway right right yeah
I kind of I did um and if if you need me
to be the person in your life that tells
you that I think I think you're a
husband's worth being honest too I think
you're being you're worth not walking
around your life um
dragging a load of bricks around with
you okay and I think you need to be very
aware this may end
everything yeah he may say I'm out right
because you did this and because I can't
trust you and because F in the
blank or he may need some space and some
time and all those things um okay it'll
be
hard but what I know is that
relationships can't survive big
secrets okay and I know there's all
stories on the internets and all that
kind of stuff um yeah that talk about I
didn't say anything for 90 years and was
the best decision I ever made whatever
great cool yeah um you found those right
yeah be the right immediately and I was
like oh thank goodness I never have to
bring this up and then it just ate me at
me about what we really need to do yeah
so so uh role playay this with me real
quick how does it work that's my next
question like I I don't know because
there's never a good time like the kids
are sick okay now he's has an important
test or now it's Thanksgiving and like I
don't you know I just like I don't know
what to do or when or how yeah to bring
it
up
um what is uh what does Thanksgiving
look like for you guys um we will go to
his family's house
just with it's like his family reunion
so we would just go there for the day oh
wow yeah that would be intense but um
part of me
I don't think the news will be so
shocking I mean it will be shocking but
he won't be like I never saw this coming
because I when you said that he probably
kind of has an idea already because of
the distance or you know I feel like
he'll be like
okay not shocked like he was the first
time he even found any of this out yeah
um he'll be shocked yeah because you've
probably done a really damn good job of
convincing him that nothing else
happened yeah that's very true yeah so
he's going to be shocked he's probably
going to be shocked as much by your
dishonesty as by what happened yeah
definitely I'm I'm thinking in my head
right now whether you have this
conversation before or
after right um part of me thinks the
right thing to do is to not go pretend
with all of his
family yeah and to get a babysitter for
the kids
and
um have a conversation with them over
the next couple of days now we're
filming this show the week of
Thanksgiving and so it won't come out
until December but we're filming it now
and so okay
um the other part of me says what's
another three days what do you think
right um I think I I just am ready to
get it done yeah um
because I just the thought of even
continuing on is really hard I don't
want to move I don't want to like ruin
Thanksgiving but also or make that a bad
memory so what I'll tell you this is
gonna I'm gonna sound harsh okay but
just know what I'm saying you've already
ruined Thanksgiving okay um and so now
it's a matter
of um Thanksgiving will be a hard season
for you y'all as a couple for the next
several years okay and and Jims will be
a hard conversation for y'all as a
couple for the next however long you
know what I mean that's that's that's in
stone that's there yeah yeah
um I'm glad to hear you say that my gut
tells me is you get a babysitter today
for the kids okay and I'm GNA tell you
what I would do off the top of my head
okay okay I would have a place to stay
for me okay and I would have this
conversation um in a private place if
you think for a second it's going to go
I mean it sounds like he's a safe guy
he's not gonna he's definitely not yeah
he um these conversations are often
great with a counselor with somebody
else there okay um if you have a mentor
couple that knows you may want to let
them know that this is happening and
they can be there with you or if you
have full trust and uh my wife would
want me to have this conversation with
her in person
then she could kill me and no one would
ever ever find the body right um but
every couple's different okay um but you
need to get your kids out of the home
and then have a place to go and you can
offer it I've got a hotel that I've put
a deposit on and I'm willing to go if
you want me to go spend the night
somewhere else right and he may say no I
don't want that whatever but I think
that's a a fair statement just you may
need a night to cool off yeah okay and
know that he may say I don't want you
coming around my family during thanks
our family during Thanksgiving um or
maybe we're going to do Thanksgiving or
none of us are going you everything gets
sideways and that's where you need to be
pretty loose hold everything pretty
loose and be accommodating um because
you're going to blow his world up yep
for a second time
right
yes if you could go back and do this
over again would you do it different
what would you do
different I would have told him the
first time he he found out that
everything about everything for sure
let's back up before
that oh
um well I would not be talking to
somebody like I wasn't married yeah or
not how do I say it like um presenting
myself as single or maybe that I just
wasn't fully committed to my marriage or
something gotcha like it it was out of
control
yeah so here we are right yep so do me a
favor Natalie um I want you to let me
know how the conversation goes okay okay
and I'll also tell you one piece of
advice I learned from a crisis responder
that works here too M facts are your
friends don't beat around the bush be
very direct and be very
short-winded okay okay got it I've been
lying to you for the last two months I
did sleep with this guy and I couldn't
lie to you anymore you're worth more
than that and I love you and I realize I
screwed up and I had to say it period
and that's where the conversation stops
okay okay not a long drawn out story of
of of yeah um but a be direct and be
incredibly honest and
um and then go from there okay okay I
will let me know how that goes I will
and uh we'll be thinking about you okay
okay thank you thank you so much all
[Music]
right hey what's up delone here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non-anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at John
delone.org
and it goes like
[Music]
this
I am an annoying boy P pom
pom I'm playing a drum for an exhausted
preg recently pregnant just giving birth
new
Momom
gosh the sing the the author that song
thought they were doing the world a
favor they were
not I love you guys go have fun throw
snowballs at each other do something
kind for someone else love you guys
bye